some say that the german general
election in september is the most
important election this year i'm in
front of the white house
to talk with jeffrey rathkey about the
us perspective
what america expects from the next
chancellor and what each party
stands for jeffrey reyesky is the
president of the american institute for
contemporary german studies at the johns
hopkins university
thank you so much for making time for
deutsche welle jeffrey
so some say these are the most important
elections this year do you agree
oh absolutely the the bundestag election
on september 26th
is the most important election happening
anywhere in the world this year
in my view because germany is at the
heart of europe
germany defines in many ways the
direction that europe takes
and it's a crucial part of the
transatlantic
bond so this is undoubtedly going to be
a major event on the political landscape
germany has a very different system than
the united states we have several
parties uh not only two as here maybe
you can talk a little bit
why that matters sure a parliamentary
system
in which you have many parties
represented
more parties now than than ever before
in german
in recent german history it means that
any government has to be
formed as a coalition nobody has an
absolute majority on
on his own and therefore that means
compromise
so it means that nobody gets exactly
what they want
and it means also that people in the
united states who are
thinking about the impact on the
german-american relationship
have to take into account this coalition
dynamic this compromise which is going
to
characterize german politics in the
future as it always has
what does that mean for reliability the
the tendency in germany to have a
negotiated coalition agreement it gives
a certain amount of predictability
and i would say the problem is in some
ways perhaps
in the opposite direction because
parties in germany
uh when they form a government they have
a written coalition agreement which is
often dozens
if not more pages long there is a desire
to try to anticipate everything
you can't anticipate everything and so
it's that
that can give a lack of flexibility um
to
future actions because things that are
not covered in the coalition agreement
then have to be hammered out
anew and there can be a reluctance to
deviate
from those agreements so i think it's
it's more a question of
um having enough flexibility to react
to the way the world is going to change
rather than predictability about what
your positions are today
and for the next couple of months as you
are an expert
on international affairs maybe we can
talk a little bit about the
expectations of the three biggest
parties i think that
the chancellor merkel having been in
power for 16 years
there is an expectation of a certain
continuity
and there you see from an american
perspective
that the chancellor has been on the one
hand
concerned about holding europe together
the european union
especially through a number of crises
now
germany as the largest and the richest
country in europe
has the delicate task of trying to
bring together the ambitions of those
who
want more european integration and they
want it faster
with those who are more skeptical and
and in that sense germany is a
compromise broker rather than a
at the vanguard of new innovations
instead it's sort of a moderating force
and i think that when you
look at europe armin lashith the
chancellor candidate from the cdu csu
has has said that he will think european
and he will act european that he has a
european instinct
and so i think that would be something
to look for
from a government that he might lead
how will it seek to strengthen the
european level of policy making
and what concessions will germany be
willing to offer its european partners
in order to achieve that greater degree
of cohesion
will that be on the financial or the
fiscal side will that be in foreign
policy
or will it be in other areas as for now
it looks as you just said very likely
that he might be
the successor of angela merkel talk a
little bit about his take on the
transatlantic relationship
if you talk about the transatlantic
relationship the cdu and csu
have always tried to characterize
themselves
as as real advocates staunch advocates
of a strong transatlantic bond and that
has
held regardless of the president in
power in the united states there have
been
major ups and downs in the relationship
but that uh
that real um adherence to the
transatlantic pillar
um as one of the two most important
aspects of german foreign policy
on the one hand the united states on the
other hand the european union
is is at the center of the cdu's view
of the world let's talk a little bit
about olaf schultz he's from the social
democrats they have a traditionally a
closer relationship to russia gerhard
schroeder one of the
chancellors from the social democrats
was kind of the
mastermind behind behind north stream
two
what what is your take on olaf schultz
when it comes to the
german-american relationship i think
olaf schultz if you listen to
the way he has portrayed his view
of of the world and of germany's place
in the world
and if you look at the way he has uh
talked about
the biden administration i think he has
sought to
uh align them quite closely to to tell
german voters in a way i know how to
work
with the u.s administration under
president joe biden
and and i think that encompasses
not only some of the traditional foreign
policy elements i think we'll come back
in a second
to russia and to north stream too but
it's also about
the global economy what kind of
regulations should there be in the
global economy olaf schultz
along with the united states government
have talked a lot about
the minimum tax on international
corporations and that has been achieved
an agreement in the g7 context also in
g20
now it's a question of turning that into
national obligations
but i think there you see an area where
the social democrats
have tried to present themselves in a
way as
transatlanticists for the global the
digitized global economy
now when it comes to russia i think
you're absolutely right people in the
united states who look at the russia
policies
of germany and europe one of the first
things that they focus on
is the north stream 2 pipeline project
and
and i think chancellor merkel of course
has defended that project
and she has seen through an agreement
with the united states
about how that might move forward but i
think people still see that as primarily
a social democratic party
initiative and and the priority and
there i think there's just a
major disagreement uh in both american
parties the democrats and the
republicans
um are quite critical of north stream
two and
uh and and that stance isn't going to
change
then there are the greens there were
times when people
were expecting hoping fearing that
analina berbock might become the next
chancellor
what i think you see from an american
perspective is how strongly
the values orientation comes through
in the greens foreign policy vision
you can see that when you look at
questions that relate to china
and especially things like forced labor
and the
the importance of human rights including
the implications of human rights policy
for germany's international economic
engagement there i think the greens are
they try to go much further than than
other parties in germany
uh have gone thus far if you look at
russia policy
i think you see also a not only a
criticism of russian foreign policy but
more fundamentally
a a deep
not only disappointment but a deep
concern
about human rights in russia about the
nature of vladimir putin's regime
and about the implications that has for
stability in russia
and russia's role in its immediate
neighborhood and more broadly
in europe and in the world so i think
there you see a
values-driven alignment that is very
similar
to the way joe biden talks about the
competition between democracies and
autocracies as
one of the defining elements of the
international situation today
do you have an idea whom the biden
administration
would kind of prefer
well i think they would be careful never
to express a preference um
because you know there's there's there's
nothing to be gained by
uh trying to weigh in in advance of an
election
it can only backfire um and be used
against you
i i think that what people in the biden
administration
recognize is that any german government
is going to be the result of compromise
and concessions among the parties so
that's the first thing
is don't read the party program of one
party and assume that that will
that will shape um the germany
of the future but i think you can also
look at uh
these positions and see how germany's
foreign policy might evolve
and there i think you can find something
you know something for everyone if you
on the one hand the continuity and the
transatlantic commitment in the cdu csu
approach on the other hand the the views
of the global economy
that uh the social democrats uh bring um
or
the the values-driven uh
imperative of the greens uh program
so i think people will be looking for
new leadership new uh personalities and
trying to forge constructive working
partnerships
with whoever emerges you know we also we
haven't talked about the
the liberals the the free democrats uh
there's also i think a significant
likelihood that they might be part
of a future german government and and
there i think you also see
um you know a you see a bit of the
values
basis in the fdp's election program
and and i think it's a reminder
that this may be the most complicated
german government
that we've seen in recent history i
think we have to
talk a little bit at the end of this
interview about angela merkel after 16
years in office that's a long period
she shaped the understanding of germany
uh for a whole generation
generation i think also in the united
states she's very well known
what is her legacy when it comes to the
transatlantic relationship
how long do we have
let's say two minutes okay two minutes
um
so i think that miracle's legacy is
uh you know it is on the one hand a
commitment to preserving
a working german-american partnership
and a transatlantic relationship
you see this in the way she took heat
at the start of her chancellorship for
finding ways to work closely with
president george w bush
um america's popularity uh in germany
was at a low point when she took office
in
2005 and so you know it's important to
remember
that she has stood for a strong
partnership with the united states
even when it was unpopular i think you
see that as well
during the presidency of donald trump
although in that case you see merkel
i think drawing distinctions to a
greater degree
between uh german policies german
disagreements
with the united states while at the same
time recognizing
the essential importance of that
relationship
and then i think you also have to look
at her
commitment to keeping the european union
functional and together on major issues
that is a is hugely important for the
united states as well
chaos in europe is not good for the
united states that does not benefit us
and having someone who is able to take
the long view
and to foster a strong european union
and and a strong european contribution
to transatlantic security in nato
is really crucially important jeffrey
thank you so much
that shall be continued after the
election and then we discuss the outcome
and the implication for the u.s german
relationship i look forward to it thanks
so much